speaking of Alphas though I I don't this
is this is a complete [ __ ] tangent
right because like one of the coolest
pieces of culture I I just I think about
and I just talk about Alphas for some
reason remind me of this yeah
um just like the New Zealand what's
what's the New Zealand dance called Haka
Haka bro that's like that is Alpha like
I'm thinking about okay what piece of
culture from your home country are you
proud of because I think out of
everything that I can think of in Terms
like every country Haka is by far one of
the coolest pieces of culture I just I
have just seen I agree just like being
being broadcasted in the world right my
favorite is like when the the New
Zealand rugby team yeah they do a Haka
before every single match right because
it's tradition yeah but at the same time
it's also [ __ ] hilarious seeing the
opposite team just watching that and
[ __ ] themselves yeah because like
you try to like keep your cool but how
do you even react to that it is one of
the most intimidating things it is it's
a witness especially when it's like 250
kilo
yeah they could get [ __ ] destroyed in
that match and I I don't care because
all I'm gonna remember is that first
like they went into it with an alpha
they were the real Alphas they came out
the alphas man they don't need to win a
really cool video as well like and and
because I remember there was a moment
where I was just like obsessed with the
Haka because I thought it was just such
a [ __ ] cool thing right
um but like there's this really cool
video that I saw and like I I looked
into like you know what the hacker is
and like what the significance of it is
and stuff like that and it's it's this
traditional dance that's done by the
maoris which are the indigenous new
zealanders
um but there's this really cool one
where they do it at weddings as well and
there's this really cool video of this
like uh Maori woman marrying uh a white
guy like from New Zealand and the and
the Maori woman her family does a hawker
for her to be initiated into this
marriage yeah and it's really bizarre
but also really [ __ ] cool I've seen
that video because out of context you're
like because they're doing this Haka
dance right which is in these like suits
it's like isn't the hawk and it didn't
it come from like a war dance that they
would do before going to [ __ ] War to
intimidate the other side yeah so like
you imagine this kind of War dance at a
wedding right and this this girl because
this uh the dance has so much meaning
she's like she's like crying because it
means a lot but if you don't know the
contest
it's just a bunch of buff dudes two two
like dancing to this bride go
I'm just like shouting and you're just
like what the hell is going on right now
but it's so cool because like that
particular video I wish I could remember
the name of it it's on YouTube but like
it's like it wouldn't be hard it
wouldn't be hard to find but like it's
it also shows like the translations of
what they're saying in the Maori
language yeah and it's really [ __ ]
poetic and beautiful yeah because it's
literally just like the the family being
like you are growing up up now we are
ready to let you go but we are also
ready to invite you back in yeah kind of
thing yeah and it's really cool because
like the white guy as well he's
intimidated at first but then he joins
in yeah and it's like it's such a cool
like it is such a cool [ __ ] bonding
experience that I don't think many other
cultures have I'm jealous because I wish
like I wish we had a like a culture that
was like that cool instead of just like
getting [ __ ] piss head drunk and just
passing out
you can do both yeah
if you do a hacker beforehand that just
makes it ten times more cool boys night
happens before everyone starts going to
drink he's like
have you have we spoke about uh the
culturist I just like Thailand
everything cool culture-wise that you do
it guys too
um I'm trying to think I mean I feel
like I've spoken it doesn't have to be
as intense as the Hawker but no not as
not as intense as the Hawking but I'm
not I'm trying I'm trying to think off
the top I know we have like a lot of
cultural stuff I'm trying to think of
like cultural activities that as just
like really that is cool I guess does
what would you say is like the British
thing British I don't know of any
British I know there's like the I think
I can't remember if I spoke about on the
focus for the Welsh one with the Marie
Floyd it's the one with the horse head
oh yes yes I think so yeah remember that
one someone where like uh there's a
horse skeleton uh head so this is a
skull yeah skeleton just the head the
skull and I'm like a stick and then a
white robe uh and someone underneath it
and you like knock on someone's door
they don't do any more on the doors at
least not where I grew up we do it like
all self-contained but typically the
whole tradition I can't remember why we
do it you would go around knock on doors
and then you'd have like a poetry battle
and if you won the Poetry back poetry
battle Yeah if you did like bro that's
badass
Eight Mile
well just like poetry singing is all
like a very easy spin that [ __ ] it's
like a really big part of the culture so
if you want to won the Poetry battle
yeah as the person uh knocking on the
door you get to take all of their all
like a good chunk of alcohol I think
from them
it's like damn
oh I think it was and I when I did it it
was never like that it was it was it was
different to that but there was poetry
involved it's like herbivore yeah
so poetry is like a really really
important big part of uh Welsh called
poetry and Welsh must sound so [ __ ]
bad that's what it looks like I think
you've seen this before right put it up
on screen Moodle yeah you've seen this
oh yeah yeah yeah weird
um yeah I think you would I don't know
if we have anything like that in
Australia because I don't think well I
think the problem is is that our culture
just isn't really old enough yeah so
I've established tradition so I think a
lot of our Traditions are just British
ones that have lasted all kind of maybe
changed a little bit yeah or just
Traditions we've borrowed from other
countries okay because I I'd say like
the one one thing like the Americans
have definitely done like very
successfully is we we talk about what
you know we we wonder what America's
biggest export is but I think America's
most successful successful export has
been their culture yeah because everyone
in the world knows about American
culture oh yeah whether it's be like
through TV shows the soft power of uh
Hollywood yes is I mean it's insane yeah
you know and it's it's like you go you
go here to Japan you go to China you
hear songs in the Billboard 100 you know
even even if you know no one here
understands what they're saying you
still hear it here see that's
interesting you say that though because
I've heard from a lot of Americans that
claim that America has no culture oh
America does definitely have like yeah I
think I think I think they're just kind
of like blind to her but I think yeah as
you were saying like you know the fact
that you can hear [ __ ] Billy eilish
and Justin Bieber well anywhere in the
world yeah when your culture is the well
one of the most dominant cultures in the
world it's easy to think that you have
no culture because the the basis yeah
the normal is yours yeah yeah that's you
know it's not it's not the case uh also
yeah it's not poetry I forgot it's um
the householders would be expected so
you go in someone's house you ask to
enter uh to drink yeah and they they can
that you sing to each other and right
the person has to sing back and just
keep denying you and if you just keep
asking to go in and they eventually just
fold you go in and you drink
Subway so what if it just goes on
forever I assume we can just keep going
or they'll move on to another house it's
like 12 hours later they're just like no
yeah it's just to know you I know like
nearly all the traditions in Marshall
like song poetry or some kind of dancing
and folk dance see that's cool though
like we don't have anything like that in
Australia I did folk dancing in school
really I didn't re like again like when
you're doing it in school you don't
think of it as weird now that I'm
growing up I'm like okay that's weird we
dress up in these like kind of if you
would imagine I guess 1800s 1700s
dresses clothes and you just [ __ ]
dance around in circles and go in and
out and yeah it was I hated it but
that's so much cooler than like what we
like we only have like a singlet shirts
and thongs party and you listen to acpc
while drunk like that's the only culture
that we have still sounds like pretty
good fun but it's not exactly like
something you wanted you don't go up to
someone else and be like hey do you know
what we have in Australia
because I definitely like I've
definitely like found more of an
appreciation of just culture growing up
because I remember as a kid you'd be
forced to do all of these things you
know in your home country whatever
um and then you as a kid you're just
like why why do why do I do this why do
I want to do this this is weird I just
want to play video games and uh go home
and just talk to my friends on the
internet but I think like especially you
know
especially I'm like having a wedding as
well there's so many like traditions
around you know around having a wedding
right and some some of those Traditions
you don't even know what the origin of
that is like you know like taking a
piece of like taking a piece of jewelry
from you know the father-in-law or the
Mother-in-law we didn't do every
Tradition at our wedding but I know that
there are a lot of traditions with many
different cultures and many different
things is there one where you like stomp
on a wine glass or something and Judaism
oh Judaism that's right yeah yeah yeah
but then I thought about it and I'm just
like damn like this this guy invented
probably a hundred years ago and like
your ancestors and your parents chose to
like keep this tradition going on so
basically you're like kind of taking
part in history and you might not even
know what that history is you don't even
know what that origin is but even just
by having this tradition uh even just by
doing this tradition you're like taking
part in like a lineage there you can't
even see the beginning of I'm like damn
that's and when I think about it like
that that's pretty damn cool when you
phrase it like that it's pretty fun yeah
yeah yeah so that's that's why I've
definitely grown more of an appreciation
of different world cultures and
different worldly activities which is
why I look at the Haka and I'm like damn
do I have any dude does my [ __ ] does my
Heritage have anything that cool because
I I want something that cool I'm sure
Thailand has something right like it
might not necessarily be like an
interpretive dance or whatever but I
know like a lot of Southeast Asian
countries have a lot of like I mean
there's a shitload of History yeah we
have like traditional Thai dancers
um but it's this I guess this is like
the downside of not growing up in this
Home Country which is I wasn't exposed
to a lot of this because I grew up in
England so I'd only see this I guess on
a like like tip of the ice on the tip of
the iceberg thing